Wow I'm a nostalgic guy remember it so
you don't have to well we've all heard
about the Graduate the comedy stable of
the 1960's that launched Dustin
Hoffman's career and practically coined
the term Cougar and arguably plastics a
whole generation of hippies and hipsters
loved its artistic style and rebellious
nature but many seem to be split on the
relevance of the ending some saying it's
a happy end to a happy adventure others
saying it's a sad conclusion to a series
of life mistakes no I may be just a
humble critic but I do have my own
opinion on what I think this ending
means which I'd to here a boys and girls
Oh too bad
you clicked on the damn thing now keep
in mind this is an analysis of the
film's ending which naturally means we
have to analyze the rest of the film too
so there will be some major spoilers
with that said Benjamin is a college
graduate who doesn't know what he wants
to do with his life all he knows is that
he wants to be different I wanted to be
to be one
certainly do take a different turn with
his parents friend mrs. Robinson
proposes that the two of them have an
affair at first he's terrified but under
the demeaning control of his eccentric
parents he finds breaking the rules of
authority suddenly sounds very promising
so he visits her off and on throughout
the summer never letting anyone
especially her husband ever find out
over time he finds out more and more
about her like why she married her
husband if he obviously is not
interested in him oh no you had to marry
him because you got pregnant are you
shocked
and by society rules and even the fair
case of logical reasons the couple found
themselves stuck this doesn't bother
Benjamin too much until her daughter
Elaine is said to be coming into town
mrs. Robinson forbids him to see Elaine
but he accidentally gets roped in once
again feeling his inner rebel coming out
he defies mrs. Robinson's harsh orders
and decides to keep seeing Elaine anyway
salting and her finding out about them
and the family splitting up but that
can't stop what Benjamin now feels his
love meant to be so he takes a road trip
to Elaine's school and proposes that
they keep going out in fact he proposes
that he proposes that's right he has her
to marry him take him back by his offer
she finds herself confused and not
really sure what to do her parents know
though she's going to marry another boy
who has his life ahead of him and all
sorts of high expectations but when
Benjamin interrupts the wedding she sees
the true face of her parents control and
decides to run away and be with Ben
hitching a ride on a bus and riding off
into the sunset living happily ever
after or are they if they just got onto
the bus and ended with them laughing
maybe this could be considered a cheesy
romantic comedy with maybe a bit of an
artistic edge but it holds on them
riding the bus in silence as their smile
slowly fade away
why include this if this was just
supposed to be your typical happy ending
well let's really look at the story
again all throughout the film both are
lovers fight against parental
authorities that clearly want to have
them under their control but when does
the movie ever say that what they're
doing is a
good idea we'll get this film through
the goggles of rebellion rather than
doing something because it's what they
want to do they're doing it because they
can strike back at their parents and
society social statuses wouldn't that
make more sense as to why Benjamin would
want to marry Elaine after only going
out one a date and a half yeah a little
weird isn't it when that make just as
much sense as she didn't have much
interest in Ben after she found out
about the affair but then seeing her
parents trying to control her a result
in her inner rebel coming out as well
the two get so wrapped up in fighting
what they don't want that they rush
towards something that they slowly
realize maybe they didn't want either a
date and a half and then they're ready
to get married huh maybe in this ending
scene it all suddenly hits them what
they've done and what they committed to
and when there's no more authorities to
fight against they suddenly start to
question whether or not this was the
right choice the very famous song sound
of silence it's played a couple of times
in this movie you ever wonder why it's
played once in the opening when he
returns from college another while
having the affair and then at the very
end when he crashes the wedding
literally so why these three moments
specifically was because they just
realized they had a popular song and
they should put it in to sell the
soundtrack more well here's a crazy
fucking idea that maybe more movie
should catch on to the song actually
serves a purpose sound of silence as
many of you know is not a very happy
song it's about the emptiness that
surround us and whether or not there's a
way to escape it all three times it's
played in the film
Benjamin is debating whether or not he's
content with his life or miserable with
it as he himself is not really sure
remember this is a kid right out of
college he has his whole life ahead of
him and no idea what he wants to do with
it his only friends are his parents
friends who have less interest in him
that they do making themselves look good
he's barely done anything risky in his
life so the first time something
different comes along something
dangerous something new something
exciting
he understandably jumps at it whether
it's really in his best interest or not
he confuses this fighting back for his
destiny what he really wants rather than
young rebellion that just needs to run
its course he's so passionate about
though that he convinces Elaine
her wedding day that she should have the
same passion to so when they run away
together at the very end are they in
love well they think they are but that
emptiness still seems to be there that
same sound of silence that was played in
the opening only this time unlike the
opening rather than having all these
possibilities ahead of them
they're both stuck neither of them would
tell the other that they want to back
out now
especially after making such a grand
escape like that one whether out of
pride or fear the two are bound to each
other with no way of escape just like
mrs. Robinson if you remember she also
made some rebellious mistakes and had to
spend the rest of her life dealing with
it and ironically the more she tries to
push Ben and Elaine away from making the
same mistakes the more she forces them
to do the exact same thing does that
make the parents right in this film
really both are still overprotective and
over controlling but that doesn't make
our young lovers right either both fight
for their independence so much that they
never really question what they wanted
to do with their independence both
rushed in not really sure of what they
wanted but rather than figuring it out
slowly and patiently they grabbed the
bull by the horns never asking
themselves why they were grabbing those
horns to begin with so there is no real
good guy or bad guy in this story it's a
cautionary tale of what happens when the
natural act of a young rebellion is not
allowed to be explored much like Romeo
and Juliet
when it's delayed to controlled or built
up to a point beyond logical reasoning
in all likelihood Benjamin and Elaine
are probably doomed to repeat the exact
same mistakes that mrs. Robinson and her
husband did demonstrating how too much
control and responsibility can result in
a longing for too much freedom and too
little responsibility many still look at
this film as a charming love story the
same way Disney characters can only go
on a few dates and suddenly get married
and if that's what you see
and Who am I to stop you but for those
who think it isn't anything more and
that the film should be criticized for
being nothing but that
ask that you look at your own rebellious
youth and the choices you made question
how similar that desire to fight back
was to Benjamin's and how if you were
restrained even more
how would you naturally want to fight
back maybe you'll see that bus ride a
little differently maybe you'll see the
symbols like the sign saying do they
match a little differently or the empty
drifting and drowning of the water
constantly surrounding him a little
differently or the placement of the
famous song not just being there because
it's a famous song a little differently
for me this is the bus ride I always saw
and maybe you saw it too or maybe you
saw a different one but in my world it's
a constant reminder of how it's always
best to slowly figure out what you want
rather than rush into something you're
unsure about because fighting too
quickly for your freedom can result in
making your prison bars even stronger
and if you're still not convinced that
what he did was the right choice take a
look how he turns out a few years later
Wow love's a bitch Alan this does your
credit guy remember so you don't have to
you